let me pull up this story from the daily
mail this is uh Luke had just mentioned
this a moment ago Daily Mail says what
homeless crisis dozens of rooms and
properties are available on Airbnb in
Martha's Vineyard after homelessness
director claimed 50 illegal immigrants
could not stay because there's no
affordable housing it's a big lie they
look pull up Airbnb and you will see the
dozens several dozen properties that are
vacant right now and I I know you might
be saying but Tim those are that's
private property you can't just force
I'm gonna Force anybody the local
government of all of these very wealthy
individuals who pay very very large
property taxes can spend the 200 per
night to house these people until they
can find a place for them I don't see
I'm not even trying to be cute here
if these people showed up and said what
do we do with them okay it's going to
cost us 10 grand we're going to find
them a home for three days to make them
make sure they're comfortable well taken
care of and well fed we can easily
afford the 10 grand then we'll find a
place that's more permanent or a way to
transition them to something more
permanent instead what do they do they
call the National Guard ship them off to
a military base oh they also had a
GoFundMe they started 36
36 a race I have another homeless
wrinkle as it pertains to immigration
that it's exposed something which is
that in the city of Los Angeles we have
150 000 people sitting on the streets
lying on the sidewalks sick as hell but
any event uh and we've had roughly 500
000 undocumented workers come into the
city give or take
of those 500 000 people they have no
home no money no family no job no
passport they're there illegally I I
dare you to find one on the street it's
a housing problem and yet people with
that kind of of a of a of a burden find
housing you know they have nothing and
they find housing not one of them on the
street out of 500 000. I used to live in
LA and I worked at a restaurant with
illegal immigrants that were working in
the kitchen and they had like their own
housing structure set up that only they
could live at and it was Dirt Cheap like
100 bucks a month
but they no it's not that so much they'd
live in would they get eight or ten of
them together and they'd get a place you
know they'd go do it and they'd survive
and they'd work real hard and they'd
then they'd move out find another place
I think someone was funding their cheap
rent I I think it was like a an
organization was making sure they had a
place to stay for very cheap that makes
sense
even if you pay even if these companies
are paying illegal immigrants they don't
pay taxes so they say like so if they
pay an illegal immigrant minimum wage it
wasn't my company that I was working at
it was like another illegal immigration
company or group that was like making
sure I don't know I don't know why their
rent was so super cheap in in on Sunset
but he's getting Silver Lake La yeah is
that is that the thing is the benefits
yeah the benefits as Alex Jones has it
all the time key Bono and the worst part
was that they were amazing people this
is what's so crazy yes
but it's just the harsh reality of
putting too many people together at once
I I just it it makes me feel like you
know uh I mentioned this before the show
I mentioned mentioned it earlier on my
other show
um it's the fall of the Roman Republic
not the Roman Empire
um and a lot of people have likened
what's happening now to the Roman Empire
and maybe I don't know I was just
reading and I was like oh it sounds like
the Roman Republic like someone comes in
because someone super chatted this
yesterday saying that Caesar Crossing
the Rubicon wasn't the end it was
transforming the Republic into the
Empire which made it last for another
200 you know another two centuries and
so I was thinking about that right you
bring up the homeless problem we've had
a homeless problem in La for what
decades several decades and now we have
Mass immigration problem Mass illegal
immigration problem how are we supposed
to accommodate more people when we can't
even accommodate our own it's just going
to crumble and fall between but we could
accommodate them we refuse to Powers we
actively we actively have laws and
systems that prevent us from treating
these poor people like how would we do
it oh my God it'd be so simple I mean
these are all my patients these are look
if you took that same population and put
them in four walls in a room and they
were dying at the rate they're dying
right now that that's a hospital except
there are no doctors and no nurses and
doctors and nurses are not allowed to
interact with them or deal with them at
all until they get so sick they end up
in the ER and then if they say I have a
place to eat I have two bucks for
McDonald's I have a place to live that's
my tent over there that's it you can and
I don't want to kill myself and somebody
else you can't keep them the hospital
can't keep them no you can't keep it so
so are you saying these are people with
like um drug addiction schizophrenia
bipolar oh it's just a mess it's just
it's just a open-air Asylum now these
people with uh schizophrenia bipolar
disorder if they were given medication
would they Thrive we I worked with the
state senate for a while trying to get
trying to get a law passed to just be to
take the heat off a little bit because
we sent families up there and families
like look I have money I have doctors
ready to go I have a bed for my son
please help me bring him in he doesn't
want to come in because it's part of the
the illness they have something called
the anesagnosia they're blocked and
seeing what's going on with them they
think they're living their best life
they're just getting sicker and sicker
and they die and anise acknowledges a
neurological term it just means kind of
like denial and uh and they just tell
them to scram get out of here get out of
here who are you to say
it's like it's on purpose isn't it yes
it's disgusting
is it terrible why is this why why it's
a you know I I did a documentary called
Beyond homelessness with the Salvation
Army sort of making the rounds now and
the woman that spearheaded that did the
interviews and stuff I was with her at a
film festival I said I said I'm so tired
I just can't do it anymore I can't do it
no please keep going I go I go I can't
fight these guys I know you know what
what can we reason with them and she
turned to me she snapped me she goes
it's a religion for them it's a religion
you can't reason with them I thought oh
great and the religion is people are
free to do whatever there's no such
thing as brain diseases there's no such
thing that affects free will there's no
such thing that affects judgment there's
nothing the only disease is dementia
that one if you don't treat you've
abused a patient and it is the same
exact symptom complex
and all the studies and what we knew
about dementia was also artificially
inflated by a scientist that just made
science up but that was also a recent
scientific finding as well and Ian you
ask why do you think the government
cares about you Ian do you think the
government ever cares about you or do
you think they're there to provide a
service they don't absolutely wrong Luke
I disagree you're completely wrong wrong
excuse me the government cares about you
because if yeah if you're not around
then your tax is coming exactly exactly
California they really need you so they
they see you as like um you know a fresh
ripe Apple to be Juiced to just just
squeeze as much as they can and look I
got an apple tree do I care about the
apples well look I'm not gonna go save
the apples when they're injured rotting
or whatever I'm gonna throw them in the
garbage but I care about them in so far
as I would like to take the ones that
are good and use them for food and juice
is it the problem where you can't the
California doesn't want you to be able
to go take someone off the stream be
like you're sick come with me yeah
nothing like that oh my God can the
people there's no voluntarily come into
the hospital not when they're sick like
that that's very rare but it's it's you
know look the term we used to be able to
keep people for suicide homicide and
Gravely disabled Gravely disabled is
essentially gone and great what is
Stables what is what's going on what if
uh what if we did this what if we uh you
know just put lithium in the drinking
water from
fox.com in 2018. how our drinking water
could help prevent suicide put lithium
in the water and that's that's scary
right yeah are they really talking about
it yes this is vox.com this is
mainstream nbcfunded vox.com putting an
article out wow arguing that we should
put lithium in our drinking water to
kind of desensitize people this is
because they found that people who lived
near water sources that had lithium were
much happier
we're like all right let's do it quote
unquote happier well I mean you knock on
the door and they're like hello yeah in
the right dose I think it would probably
be good for you I imagine it's the third
element I mean it's gotta have something
Nation this is fluoridation all over
again well but this as is psychoactive
yeah right yeah and it's bad for your
kids so like top-down missions
what's your experience with top-down
medicine because I find like like saying
this is the vaccine everyone needs it
whereas everyone's different the
centralization of medicine is one of the
biggest catastrophes I've ever seen
Menace is best practice a highly trained
caring physician motivated informed
patient that is your most efficient unit
period anything else screws it up and
now you know in medicine look I didn't
realize 80 of Physicians are employed
now so when all these Physicians froze
in place and stop treating patients I
couldn't understand what was happening
well they got word from on high from the
centralized Authority just sent him home
and that was it yeah it was a psychopath
and that's crazy and they didn't they
didn't even talk about early treatments
they didn't even talk about nothing
preventative treatment okay they were
told they were told they were instructed
to shut up don't do it
so I got sick
and then um I felt fine and I was like I
just feel like I'm a little sick then it
got bad and I was like I'm gonna call
because maybe there's a protocol for
this that I'm not aware of and you know
I'm I'm somebody who reads constantly
but I was like maybe they'll say like
hey take this vitamin and do this or
otherwise I called the local uh hospital
and they went
go to sleep yeah and then I was like
monitor your po2 that's it and they were
like just go to sleep they didn't tell
me to do anything and then that night I
got really bad and I was shaking and so
I was like man if the if I got to call
Joe Rogan that's you know it's the only
thing I can do that's what I always
think when I get sick
but in all seriousness it was um I had
talked to a doctor and they said there's
nothing you can do but I knew from the
news not even from talking to Joe that
he had gotten monoclonal antibodies and
I said maybe maybe there's something he
knows by the way his treatment was like
a year into the pandemic we had that
stuff for six months before that right
it's easy now uh that to me is a public
health failure they should have been
educating people how to they want to
save lives educate people how to deal
with their this is the crazy thing so uh
I we we all got sick we all got the
monoclonal antibodies and we were all
like just overnight just better it was a
weird experience and then I remember
um hearing from my doctor that they were
actually struggling to get more
monoclonal antibodies at a certain point
there was a moment right around the time
you probably got sick where they had
trouble Distributing it trouble getting
it trouble accessing it but they were
saying it was because the government was
shutting it down yeah they were they
were making it harder to get and then I
think what Biden said no to it well you
know what it was how they destroyed I
think they started sending it into areas
of risk you know what I mean well no
Biden tried to take it away from Florida
and Florida and Santos had to fight back
saying no stopped trying to take it away
from us and then they limited it because
they said it was quote ineffective which
absolutely made no sense at all and was
not backed by any side one of the things
that I've learned about public health is
it's not about medicine they're many of
them are not even biologically trained
certainly not clinically trained it's
about Equity that is the new Public
Health Mantra and if and that was not
the right it's an important prism I get
it's important but it's not the whole
story and it was not useful or not
important in terms of getting through
this particular pandemic what wasn't
there somewhere there was people in
Texas denied antibodies because they
were the wrong color that happened to
Patient of mine yeah which is absolutely
mind-boggling which is absolutely crazy
you take care of someone depending on
how much they need to be taken care of
not because of the way that they were
born with a particular skin color and
this happened in the United States
there's a viral video of a guy filming
as the nurse is telling him you don't
qualify he's why not she's like oh
you're white
it's absolutely mindful no no I forgot
about this chapter it's interesting I'd
really forgotten about it but I remember
they were reallocating it and sending it
places where you couldn't get it but
that's that was the deal yeah I had a
patient really get really sick with it
now he was it was probably Omicron and
because before we had Elmo cross Pacific
and monoclonals so I wasn't that at the
time that upset about it but I thought
man
it might have helped him because he got
really sick that's just yeah I mean
that's a violation of the Civil Rights
Act people died because they were
specific criteria that he did not meet
just these criteria that was has that
changed the most important criteria was
the color of your skin it was the same
thing with the vaccine roll out too
remember I couldn't the reason I got
covered I couldn't get the vaccine
because I wasn't the right as that first
Equity role I remember that they started
yet yep marginalized people first right
and I couldn't get it and even though I
was treating covet at the time so and I
was going to go I was gonna go volunteer
my time in the ER they lost me because
and that's why it's important to point
out that the CEO of these big Pharma
companies are very good honorable people
because they chose not to get the
vaccine yeah because people couldn't
like the sacklers they're very honorable
the way they the way they told people
that uh what is it is it addictive uh
yeah I could go all day on the opioid
crisis
well you know we have baby 2098 in
California now we're doctoring of the
license taken away if they give out
misinformation
that says if any doctor is uh found to
be giving out misinformation that it
deviates from the standard of care their
their license could be what's the
standard that's the problem I've seen
standard of care when I when I first got
to the psychiatric I would start working
at Psychiatric Hospital in 1985 when I
first got there I acquired about two
dozen patients that were the subjects of
the standard of care in the late 40s and
50s somebody put an ice pick up above
their eye and swooped it back and forth
and they were disasters disasters and
that was the standard of care then I had
to live through the opioid standard of
care pain is the fifth Vital sign
remember that pain is what the patient
says it is pain control is what the
patient says it is they also started
Prosecuting Physicians for inadequate
treatment of pain so we all froze and we
we all froze and said everything to the
pain doctors the pain management guys
who felt that anybody that didn't use as
much opiates as possible as opiophobic
patients are in control let them decide
what they need and my patients are being
killed hand over fist thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there